how do you say syrup syrup syrup syrup
no syrup syrup right this is my jam I'm
an egg guy I'm a waffle man I don't
usually eat breakfast
everybody should probably serve
breakfast menus 24 hours I'm into it
adventures okay
banana scrambled eggs this looks
interesting it looks more like an
oatmeal yep
that's actually really good I like that
a lot the next thing is good taste I got
like a bread pudding or something never
again for me grilled cheese donut
grilled cheese donut hole I feel like if
I was on a date with a guy and I made
this you would just feel like you are
the woman for me you made me a grilled
cheese doughnut and then he would marry
me well I would eat this with a slice of
bacon on the inside this is mad yeah I
was right I would definitely try to make
this by myself if I was allowed to use
this stove Buchanan banana muffin bacon
and banana muffins the cheese on top
it's quite cute adorable it's not as
muffiny where it's usually like dry and
crumbly yeah it's not crumbly it's like
a moist cupcake it tastes like banana
bread with bacon and cheese I just
finished my absolute this is a legit
breakfast muffin bacon and syrup
pancakes do you want to eat with your
hands I kind of want I'm just going like
a dog I'm like looking through this this
bacon is perfect it's crispier than it
even looks it's so perfect and the
pancakes are really fluffy gosh such a
good choice it is the essence of
compromise in which neither flavour is
happy this is the kind of thing that I
would eat for eternity
every day you put a ring on this this is
what breakfast is all about
I'm feeling so hyper so much sugar your
pregnant wife is gonna be psyched for
all of these dude oh my goodness she'd
just be my little taste test dummy over
there about a dummy you're not a dummy
I'm just saying no dummy here in China
all right I know